on continue à dérouler le fil de
l'actualité de celui novembre sur notre
antenne avec alice gastines la chronique
de l'éco montsort wilfried bonsoir à
tous alors ce soir donc j'ai choisi de
m'intéresser à l'auto entreprenariat à
l'occasion du premier forum organisé par
la ville de plaisir ce jeudi ce statut à
4 ans d'existence cette année environ
900 mille auto entrepreneurs en france
dont près de 18 mille trois cents dans
les yvelines grégoire leclercq bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes président de la
fédération française des auto
entrepreneurs alors pour commencer on va
rappeler ensemble un petit peu le
fonctionnement de ce statut alors le
régime de l'auto-entrepreneur fonctionne
de manière extrêmement simple sur la
base de quatre points clés l'inscription
est facilitée sur internet ont peu près
en dix minutes on ne paye pas de tva on
n'est pas assujetti à la tva
bien sûr ce qui implique de ne pas la
facturer aux clients mais pas non plus
de la récupérer on a un fonctionnement
qui implique que si on ne fait pas de
chiffre d'affaires ne paye pas de
charges ce qu'on appelle le système
micro fiscal micro social et les charges
sont payées en pourcentage du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé alors on va revenir
en détail sur tous ces points avec des
auto entrepreneurs que nous avons
rencontrés lors de ce forum à plaisir 22
auto entrepreneurs de la ville étaient
présents on écoute l'adjointe au maire
chargée de l'économie qui nous explique
la démarche de la ville
je crois qu'il était aujourd'hui puisque
la situation économique morose que le
statut aussi d'auto entrepreneur n'est
pas encore enfin va encore évoluer et
nous a semblé opportun de faire une
action très ciblée vers l'auto
entrepreneur qui permettra de mieux
connaître leur statut de aussi de saluer
et d'encourager leur volonté de que
d'avoir créé
la structure mais aussi de les
accompagner pour pouvoir développer
leurs activités leurs activités et de
pouvoir
donner davantage de dynamisme rigobert
leclerc est ce que c'est important que
des villes comme ici plaisir soutiennent
ce statut d'auto entrepreneur alors non
seulement c'est important mais j'ai même
envie de dire c'est fondamental cette
initiative la telle qu'elle a été montée
à plaisir c'est à peu près la cinquième
ou la sixième que la fédération des
auto-entrepreneurs soutient et encourage
en france c'est quelque chose qui
devrait à mon avis beaucoup plus
répandue pourquoi parce que l'auto
entrepreneur aujourd'hui c'est la
première pierre c'est là c'est le bas de
la pyramide de la création de
l'entreprise en france et il est
extrêmement important que cette auto
entrepreneurs s'inscrivent au niveau
local dans un paysage global
entreprenariale avec l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques du conseil général
de la mairie
les autres entreprises et ça tout ça si
vous voulez ça doit être encouragée par
les pouvoirs publics qui sont
aujourd'hui les seuls et je pense les
plus à même voir les seuls à pouvoir
faire cet effort on va dire d'insertion
professionnelle des uns avec les autres
beaucoup se lancent dans l'auto
entrepreneuriat est ce que tous
réussissent alors non bien sûr que non
le régime de l'auto entrepreneur il a 7
cet avantage fondamental qu'on ne prend
pas de risques quand on teste un projet
il a été conçu d'abord pour ça aussi
pourrait effectivement faire ressortir
du travail au noir un certain nombre
d'activités qui étaient entrés mais
aussi pour favoriser la prise de risque
prise de risque est très faible
aujourd'hui on peut dire que trois auto
entrepreneur sur quatre persévère sur un
million deux cent mille français qui ont
tenté 800000 restent encore actifs donc
c'est plutôt pas mal
sur les 800 mille trois cent cinquante
mille font vraiment du chiffre
d'affaires les autres bégué bafouille
essaye recommence certains effectivement
arrêteront mais on a avec ce dispositif
est souvent salée faits majeurs à
retenir on a avec ce dispositif mis le
pied à l'étrier à un certain nombre de
français qui n'auraient jamais tentée
autrement vous parliez du chiffre
d'affaires c'est intéressant de regarder
ces chiffres a en france le chiffre
d'affaires moyen pour un auto
entrepreneur et de 9300 32 euros dans
les yvelines en ile-de-france même plus
globalement il est de 11 mille trois
cents euros pourquoi cette différence
est ce que c'est lié au dynamisme
économique
alors oui c'est effectivement liée au
dynamisme économique on le voit dans
toutes les grandes régions
dynamique française l'ile-de-france
rhône-alpes la zone autour de marseille
lille bordeaux qu'ils ont des activités
souvent plus liée aux services aux
entreprises et où on a un chiffre
d'affaires global qui est quand même
plus élevé avec des activités souvent
plus techniques plus poussées plus en
pointe avec un peu d'innovation et puis
un versement dans un milieu très rural
vous allez dans la corrèze la creuse
l'alsace lorraine la franche comté
on a des chiffres mois d'affaires moyen
qui peuvent descendre à 6000 7000 euros
par an avec des professions qui sont
parfois en voie de disparition ou des
petits jd chambre d'eau des choses qui
qui vivotent un peu et qui soudain un
autre régime fiscal et social ne
fonctionnerait pas mais ce qu'on peut
vivre avec ce statut d'auto entrepreneur
est ce qu'on peut gagner sa vie
véritablement correctement alors on peut
vivre avec l'origine de
l'auto-entrepreneur aujourd'hui sur les
huit cent mille français qui sont auto
entrepreneur il y en a un petit tiers
qui vit de son activité pour isoler un
complément d'activité exactement pour
tous les autres c'est un complément
d'activité ceux qui en vivent génère en
moyenne entre 25000 et 32000 euros qui
est le chiffre d'affaires maximale qu'on
peut générer en tant
qu'auto-entrepreneur autorisé autorisé
et ceux qui en vivent aujourd'hui ont
finalement deux objectifs le premier
c'est de stabiliser l'activité pour
essayer d'en vivre avec le plus
longtemps possible
et puis le deuxième objectif bien sûr
c'est de franchir des seuils de chiffre
d'affaires pour créer demain de très
souvent une sarl avec une structure
parfois à plusieurs et les associés qui
permet aussi de se reposer de souffler
on parlera peut-être de la solitude mais
c'est avec l'auto entrepreneur qui est
seul c'est un peu dur et du coup de
créer des emplois derrière donc on a des
auto-entrepreneurs peu près 70 milles
auto entrepreneur depuis 2009 qui ont
créé des emplois mais alors quel est le
profil de ces auto-entrepreneurs parce
que c'est assez large il peut y avoir
des retraités des chômeurs alors il n'y
a pas de profil type
hélas de l'auto entrepreneur globalement
on l'a dit il est ouvert depuis le puy
finalement le mineur de 16 ans jusqu'à
la personne aux retraités en passant par
les salariés les fonctionnaires les
demandeurs d'emploi les personnes sans
activité et une femme et une proportion
la proportion de femmes est à peu près
respectée que ce soit dans l'auto
entrepreneuriat dans la création
d'entreprise classique on est toujours
autour de 34 35 % de femmes
pour le reste on en pro b / masculine
un profil type qui d'ailleurs est assez
intéressant puisqu'on voit notamment les
seniors à la personne de plus de 60 ans
qui prennent une proportion extrêmement
important dans le régime de
l'auto-entrepreneur ils étaient 3 % en
2009 aujourd'hui ils sont 18% ça ça veut
peut-être dire aussi que les revenus
pour les retraités sont forcément voilà
c'est une faisons plus bas et alors il
ya effectivement une double double
enseignement premièrement c'est
effectivement ils cherchent des pensions
complémentaires à leur pension de
retraite
et ça c'est très clair et puis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
retraités aujourd'hui qui sont très en
forme physiquement psychologiquement
mentalement ils ont envie de continuer
ils sont la retraite et ils disent après
tout j'ai un savoir faire et un quart
des adresses j'ai des clients et j'ai
des gens qui me demandent de faire des
choses est plutôt bien rentrés dans le
travail au noir ou de foyers des trucs à
la petite semaine isabel finalement je
vote aux entrepreneurs jeu sa manière
légale et celle du bénef voit peut-être
écouté le témoignage d'un ex
entrepreneur vous avez rencontré auto
entrepreneurs présents et donc au forum
il y avait un professeur d'anglais
anciens vacataires de l'éducation
nationale il nous explique les avantages
qu'ils trouvent à ce statut ça me permet
de à la fois de facturer une façon peut
être intéressante pour les entreprises
d'une part tout en étant donc en étant
donc assez concurrentiel et d'autre part
bien de recevoir reconnaissance de mon
de ma prestation autrement que ce qui se
passe pour certains salariés
autre avantage non des moindres parce
que c'est quand même un métier à
vocation ça me permet d'intervenir
auprès de publics différents d'âge
différent de couches socio
professionnelles culturelles différentes
avec des objectifs qu'ils sont également
ceux qui en retour m'amène à développer
mes compétences
cette auto entrepreneurs et veut que l'
avantage pour les clients
quel est il en fait alors il faut pas
trop rapidement généralisés l' avantage
pour les clients
il ya deux cas de figure globalement un
auto entrepreneur qui facturent un
particulier n'étant pas assujettis à la
tva va pouvoir en moyenne facture est un
peu moins cher entre 5 et 15% moins cher
qu'une entreprise qui ferait à peu près
le même métier et donc là il ya une
fiction avec un petit avantage
compétitif même si c'est parce qu'on
préconise aux auto-entrepreneurs parce
qu'en réalité ils perdent démarche
derrière donc ce n'est pas forcément le
meilleur plan en revanche si le client
est un professionnel
là c'est plus gênant pour l'auto
entrepreneur puisque le professeur elle
ne récupérant pas à la tva qui n'est pas
facturé par l'auto entrepreneur on va se
retrouver souvent avec des
problématiques de compétitivité
mais comme il sera pas mis en
concurrence avec des salariés potentiels
alors il ne faut pas qu'il soit mis en
concurrence des salariés potentiels
c'est une vérif de l'auto-entrepreneur
faut pas le nier elle existe elle est
minime elle concerne à peu près 3% des
autres entrepreneurs mais elle existe
c'est une dérive contre laquelle nous
luttons depuis le début en disant
attention l'auto entrepreneuriat est
réservé à des indépendants qui crée une
activité de manière indépendante
c'est à dire qu'ils travaillent de chez
eux ou depuis un bureau en prestations
de freelance si nécessaire mais pas
effectivement dans l'entreprise comme un
salarié pourrait le faire ici il ya un
contrôle régulier comment comment est ce
qu'on peut voir c'est justement ce genre
de dérive alors il existe aujourd'hui un
contrôle des auto entrepreneurs au même
titre qu'il existe un contrôle de toutes
les entreprises de france et de navarre
l'inspection du travail réalise
d'ailleurs à ce sujet des missions de
contrôle régulières les statistiques
montrent que l'auto entrepreneur n'est
pas plus frauduleux qu'une entreprise
classique aujourd'hui autour de 3%
l'idée pour nous en tant que fédération
des auto-entrepreneurs ne réside pas
dans le contrôle mais reste dans la
prévention
ce qu'il faut c'est expliqué de mêmes la
manière la plus pédagogique possible aux
auto entrepreneurs
comment les choses se passe lorsqu'on
est patron de soi de sa propre
entreprise
alors on va écouter à nouveau en cette
auto entrepreneurs ça fait trois ans
qu'il a ce statut il compte bien le
conserver on l'écouté puis on reviendra
en détail sur l'avenir de ce statut
c'est un statut qui a ceci de
particulier de d'être extrêmement simple
en terme de création est également 2
bien ne pas vous faire payer quoi que ce
soit s'il n'y avait aucune aucune
recette ce qui par bonheur nommé
j'arrivais ne m'est jamais arrivé à
l'espace des trois années écoulées
pas de tracasseries administratives de
pas parce qu paperasserie inutile
c'est a priori un statut que je
conserverai tant que le plafond
fatidique des 30 mise je ne sais plus
très précisément le
le montant exact n'a pas été dépassée
auquel cas évidemment je chope terai
pour un autre statut que je conserverai
ainsi que d'autres aux
auto-entrepreneurs en couplage avec une
activité salariée dont classe cette auto
entrepreneurs explique bien qu'il a
uniquement ce statut pour l'instant mais
qu'il envisagerait de créer peut-être
une sarl en complément garder ce statut
d'auto entrepreneur c'est fréquent alors
là encore il faut être un peu précis
aujourd'hui lorsqu'un auto-entrepreneurs
franchi les seuils de chiffre d'affaires
effectivement il a plusieurs options
le seuil est à 32000 le sol est à 32
1600 euros pour les prestations de
services
lille est à 81 1500 euros pour les
prestations d'achat revente qui fait du
commerce pur l'objectif d'un auto
entrepreneur qui franchissent des seuils
effectivement c'est soit de créer une
société soit de rester dans l'entreprise
individuelle en passant ça ce qu'on
appelle le régime réel avec une
comptabilité la tva etc
alors pour répondre à votre question sur
est-ce que c'est fréquent ou pas à mon
goût pas assez au goût de certains trop
l'objectif finalement du régime d'auto
entrepreneur je les dis c'est de mettre
le pied à l'étrier à des français qui
peut-être cette fibre entrepreneuriale
et qui se rendait pas compte
une fois qu'on les a aidés à se
développer il faut qu'ils franchissent
les seuils de chiffre d'affaires
je pense que c'est très bon c'est très
bon pour la création d'entreprise et
c'est très bon aussi pour le dynamisme
économique de notre pays
en fait c'est un tremplin c'est un
tremplin il faut le vivre comme un
tremplin que 75 % des auto-entrepreneurs
se satisfassent d'une activité
complémentaire c'est très bien et il ya
aujourd'hui effectivement des salariés
des fonctionnaires des retraités qui ne
créeront jamais de sociétés de sarl
parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'avoir une
structure à gérer en plus de leur talent
leur travail salarié et l'auto
entreprise doit suffire en mai pour ce
qui dépasse justement le seuil autorisé
et ce qu'ils sont obligés
automatiquement en fait de créer une
nouvelle entité alors ils sont obligés
de dans le sens pas obligé de créer une
nouvelle entité ils sont obligés de
changer de fonctionnement
donc globalement ils sont obligés de
passer à la tva d'avoir une comptabilité
réel et du coup de changer un peu le
fonctionnement administratif et
comptable de l'entreprise
là où c'est pas bien si vous voulez
c'est quand on attend le dernier moment
pour basculer et notre message et ça
c'est je pense le message le plus
important c'est apprenez maintenant que
vous êtes auto-entrepreneur
rené a préparé cette bascule apprenez à
anticiper pour que le moment venu
lorsque vous franchissez les seuils vous
arrivez sur une structure dans laquelle
vous n'êtes pas complètement étranger il
n'y a pas de limite de temps à ce statut
alors c'est une très bonne question
aujourd'hui il n'a pas de limite de
temps ce statut est notre souhait est
qu'il n'y en ait pas il n'y en a jamais
eu et pour moi il n'est absolument pas
logique qu'il y en ait un puisque
lorsqu'on parle de salariés de
fonctionnaires de retraités ou des
étudiants
je vois pas pourquoi par exemple un
salarié devrait arrêter ou trois ans à
notre entreprise au bout de 18 mois au
bout de deux jours alors qu'il n'a pas
envie et finalement de passer son temps
sur cette auto entreprise il veut
conserver les deux alors hélas
visiblement certains ne semblent pas
être tout à fait d'accord avec nous
puisque aujourd'hui au parlement
on a un certain nombre de députés qui
ont fait une proposition de loi pour
limiter le régime de l'auto entrepreneur
à 18 mois je trouve cette proposition
idiote toutain mayotte pour au moins
trois raisons la première c'est que on
ne dit pas ce qu'on va faire de tous
ceux qui sont inscrits en auto
entrepreneur depuis plus de 18 mois
vont-ils devoir s'arrêter demain matin
la deuxième celui de deuxième raison
pour laquelle je trouve ça idiot c'est
que on ne dit pas assez
retraités étudiants salariés comment ils
vont pouvoir développer leurs activités
demain même s'ils sont pas encore
arrivés au 18 mois et puis la troisième
raison c'est que de toute façon si on
fait ça on va casser le dynamisme de
l'auto entreprise et de manière générale
était dynamisme de la création
d'entreprises en france ont pas envie de
créer leur entreprise
s'il ya cette limite de danse à l'aller
freiner il est très clairement ça valait
freiner et ceux qui sont déjà ce qu'ils
vont se radier est donc aujourd'hui pour
un statut qui arrive à générer 5
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
sur une année on va se retrouver à des
pertes fiscales des persos social de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
donc on va on va casser finalement alors
qu'on attend de la croissance on attend
de l'énergie on va casser saint louis un
statut donc qui va être confronté
peut-être aller nouvelle loi une
dernière question peut-être sur la
solitude du chef d'entreprise
c'est un c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui pour les auto-entrepreneurs
qui découvre en réalité ce que c'est que
de gérer une entreprise en étant tout
seul quand on est salarié quand on est
fonctionnaire on sait à peu près ce
qu'on va faire on a un schéma des tâches
la démission d'un planning cantonné aux
auto-entrepreneurs on doit tous faire
doit être au four et au moulin gérer la
comptabilité gérer les clients par la
prospection faire le site internet les
plaquettes marketing fixer les prix et
les ventes et des créations
il ya beaucoup de choses quand même et
la solitude souvent rajoutant à tout
cela un peu de de découragement on sent
les auto-entrepreneurs aujourd'hui en
attente d'une structure pour de plus en
plus les les fédérer les consolider
entre eux et d'ailleurs c'est la mission
principale de la fédération des
auto-entrepreneurs on était trois mille
en 2009 on est 50 2000 aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on sera 100 milles dans un an
il ya un vrai besoin de dialogue et de
des changes en tout cas ceux sur sur les
pratiques tu fais avec un franc le bilan
est positif parce que je pense qu'il est
très positif et il faut qu'il soit
encore plus positive demain c'est une
bonne idée gardant la merci beaucoup
d'égards leclerc pour votre venue en
plateau on parle à présent d'une
entreprise informatique qui a été créé à
guyancourt il ya une vingtaine d'années
et qui ne cesse de se développer le
recrutement des ingénieurs installé sur
notre territoire on regarde ce reportage
recruter ses salariés localement c'est
la démarche de cette société de conseil
et de services en informatique créée à
montigny au début des années 90 et qui
depuis a connu une croissance fulgurante
nos clients sont très sensibles au fait
que des ingénieurs habitons pas très
loin ne soit pas très gêné par les
transports le tissu local est aussi
assez intéressant il est vers site et
donc de versailles saint quentin
il ya des écoles qui s'implante donc
nous aussi nous cherchons à faire vivre
ce tissu local
parce que nous y croyons c'est une
société c'est une ville nouvelle donc
intéressante donc pour ça que c'est
intéressant que tout le monde puisse y
il travaille et les vivants passé de 250
à 700 salariés après le rachat l'été
dernier de la filiale française d'un
groupe américain la société a installé
son siège à paris tout en conservant un
service recherche et développement de 25
personnes à guyancourt une antenne en
fort développement puisque 50 postes
sont ouverts au recrutement
profil recherché des bac + 5 issus
d'écoles d'ingénieurs ou de l'université
une première expérience est demandé mais
pas nécessaire softeam possède en effet
une université en interne
l'avenir semble radieux pour la pme
devenue grande entreprise qui table à
présent sur un développement
international
nous avons des projets effectivement
d'internationalisation plutôt du côté
asie pour accompagner nos grands clients
certains de nos grands clients du
domaine de la finance sont évidemment
sur paris mais aussi on pense à londres
non pense aussi à hong kong singapour
notamment une demande d accompagner
softeam compte plusieurs centaines de
clients aux profils divers de la banque
aux grands groupes industriels en
passant par les assurances
elle recrute chaque année en moyenne 150
à 200 personnes
on parlait tout à l'heure au début de
cette édition des difficultés de la
société alcatel il ya d'autres
entreprises pour qui les choses
fonctionnent plutôt bien il y en a
encore une autre également qui est née à
cinquante ans l'insee yun oui tout à
fait un ses aînés à la halle à
l'initiative d'un jeune chef
d'entreprise
ahmed agne et et puis de cécile de
pournin sont associés ki moon une
société éditrice de manga ils ont appris
le japonais par passion une force face
aux professionnels du métier un son
marché nippon
la première année leur chiffre
d'affaires frôlé les 50 mille euros
aujourd'hui ils en sont à trois millions
cinq cent mille euros
il vient de sortir un manga en couleurs
à l'attention des enfants
on écoute ensemble l'armée d'amis
aujourd'hui paradoxalement sur un marché
où on a une vingtaine voire une
trentaine d'éditeurs de manga on n'a que
deux maisons d'édition dans lesquels le
directeur éditoriaux parle japonais et
ça fait une sacrée différence ne serait
ce que parce qu'on est plus réactif on
peut lire les bouquins plus tôt on
appréhende mieux leur contenu et on est
plus à même de défendre nos choix auprès
des auteurs et des éditeurs japonais
on est des grands fans de littérature
fantastique et de fantaisie au départ on
a grandi avec le seigneur des anneaux
avec narnia ce genre de choses là
et du coup cet amour pour la fantaisie
se retrouve pas mal dans le cas tel
catalogue dans le sens où on a beaucoup
de séries médiéval fantastique avec des
elfes des dragons des châteaux forts ce
genre de choses là et c'est l'édition
c'est que c'est un combat de tous les
jours parce que vous avez un succès un
jour il est plus publiés l'année d'après
il faut en trouver un nouveau pour le
remplacer
donc nous on est constamment sur la
brèche il faut tout le temps lire niveau
tout le temps repérer de nouveaux
auteurs proposer de nouvelles séries la
fois en plus de la chronique échos
aujourd'hui elle concerne les centres
commerciaux
oui exactement le centre commercial le
centre des athlètes de luxe en travaux
ou west qui devrait émerger donc aux
clayes-sous-bois d'ici qui devrait
ouvrir un fin 2013 change de nom il va
s'appeler one night in paris c'est le
nom commercial du centre détenus par la
société cattin veste et qui compte se
positionner comme le plus grand village
de marques de france à prix cassés il
devra compter avec skywest à montigny 1
qui deviendra carré privé ouest l'an
prochain qui se positionne sur le même
marché
les travaux à skywest devrait débuter au
printemps 2013 et hammerson
la foncière qui gère skywest et l'espace
saint quentin assure que la
commercialisation et déjà fait à 50%
l'agenda pour conclure quelques dates à
retenir dans la jambe haricots
exactement alors la ville de coignières
organise une journée de recrutement le
15 novembre jeudi prochain au salon
antoine de saint-exupéry et puis la
cgpme des yvelines vous proposent deux
rendez vous le 15 novembre tout d'abord
un petit déjeuner sur les groupements
employeurs et l'actualité fiscale dès
8h30 au siège à rambouillet et puis une
journée de formation ont toujours le 15
novembre prévenir et gérer les conflits
en interne de 9 heures à 17 heures à la
pépinière de versailles grand parc
et puisqu'on parle de la cgpme je peux
vous annoncer donc ce nouveau fil est qu
un qui sort les hommages de la promo à
20h30
et lui qui compte autopromo l'asie comme
sacré donc aux pme qui font face à une
actualité chargée avec notamment cette
loi des finances 2013
c'est un entretien avec geneviève bel la
présidente de la cgpme discipline pour
nous rappeler le jour et l'horaire de la
première diffusion de file echo vendredi
l'inter 30 garcia lycée on en trouve à
la semaine prochaine aussi sur ce
plateau pour le 7 8 le 7 8 qui se
poursuit toujours sur tv fils en direct
entre 18 et 19 heures avec à présent
cette opération de solidarité menées par
le sky rugby et au profit de
l'association laurette fugain